about us about five years old now I'm  dating myself I our family decided to  take a special trip this weekend and we  went from East Los Angeles area and  drove to Wilshire Boulevard to the fox  theatre i think it was even called the  fox academy theater to see a movie that  i wasn't interested in seeing because i  thought it was just a lot of music and  it was the sound of music as i kept  complaining as we were waiting in line  and getting into the theater as soon as  the movie started i was hooked it was a  story that if you would have asked me at  that age what I want to go see this  movie I said absolutely not but the  imagery the sound the picture the story  the actors it just got got into me and  later on I realized who the individuals  and what their contributions were to  make that movie and it was no accident  and it being something fantastic